>>> TONIGHT "THE WASHINGTO
POST" IS REPORTING TT UNNAMED
SERS TO TH
'S FIXATED ON A
REPUBLICAN-LED AUDIT OF THE 2020
ABOUT IT TA
SO WHAT'S TH?
>> WELL, I W STA,
ANDE SAYIN
LEE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENG  MARICOPA RSOFOTD.
E ON START
THERE ISECHAT YOU'RE
SEEING BD S CA
THIS IS LL STAT
AND THEN OVER COULD THW ITS
WH REVIEW 0
BUT THIS I ANY TALLY YOU
HAVEVER SEEN
T ANOTHER OF1 MILLION BALLOTS
COUNTY BUT THIS SO-CALLE
E ARE BALLOT COUNTER
T IT'S -- THERE'NOG
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS.
>> NO,
MOST DON'T O RE JUSO DO
STORY.
>> Reporter: OPENLY PARTISAN
YOE
AND IN WHA.
>>UPM CNN.
>> OKAY, NO, THA>> PEOPLE ARERIT
LOOK AT
OANL GHT-WING OUTLET THAT HASPE
ELECTION.
N IS LG THE EVENT,
AND ITS HOSTS
E INITIALLY TOLD WE COULD
STATS, BUTN   PUBLICLY OWNED
TRIED AGAIN ANOTHER TIME --
>> KYUNG LAH WITH N. OKAY.
YOU GUYS ARE ON TH
>>orOWED THAT FI
>> THERE IS MEDIA PARKING. UT T
>> I'M NOTUTPEAK
TO THE PRESS OR THE MEDIA.
>> Rr: EVEN THOUGH THESE
UNIFORMED MEPOLICE,
THEY'RE NO
THEY'RE LUP CALLED
THE ARIZONA RANGERS.
YOU'RE
>> Reporter: THIMAN IS WEARING
A BADGFROM CYBER NINJAS.AT T FLA
ID $150,000 BY THE GOP E TO CON
THIS REVHERE'S WHAPUK
SELLERS, THEARICOPA COUNTY
BOARD OF S C
>> EVERYTHING THEY'RE DOING IS
SO UNPROFESSIONAL THATREALLYI D
INTO THE WEEDS TOO FAR O
S THAT I SEE GOING
ON.
>> Reporter:NO
DIFFERENCE.
ALREADY CONDUCT TWO WITH BIPARE
IN PUBLIC VIEWHAFOUN
EVIDENCE ON
FRAUD.
THE ARSORS FOUGHTHE STATSEN
KEEP THE BALTSUTD
TURNED OVER THE BALLOTS.
ACCEPTONELECTION,
IT CAN'T BE ABOUT A PARTY, I
CAN'T BE ABOUT A PERSON.
IT HEPING
E VOTERS.
>> Reporter:ZOS
ES AND T L GET A REPORTER INTO T
ISAPPENING AND
SCANNED WITH UV LIGHTS.THUAL PRI
IN A NEWS CONFERENCE, THE HIRED
REPRESENTATIVE FOR T A
STATE SENATETRUGGLED
EXPLAIN WHY.E UVS FOR? UV LIGHT
THPE PVE INVOLVED
IN THEERVA FOR WHAT?
FOR ATPOSE PERSONALLY DON'T KNO
>> IT'S REALLY A FISHING
EXPEDITION FOR STUT WE
KNOW DOESN'T ESTr:OF STATE WARN
A MAYUS THEGE IN THE PLAYBOOK
AUDIT FOD AND CRIED FOR AN
THEY HAVGOTTEN IT AND E INO USES
AND GET IT
>> IT'S REALLY STUNNING.THER
I MEANTIMES, TU'RE STANDING  F
ARE THERE ANY LEGAL BATTLES ?
>> Reporter: OH, ABSOLUTELY.
OF PEOPL
TO STOP THIPROCESS.E ARIZONSEE.
THAT HE WASN'T COMPLETEL T SAY
CONVINCEAT
SIGNIFICT  BEING
BUT ON TSELIGH
LEARNING A LITTLE BIMO
THE ESUSE THE JUDGE
SAID YOU'VE GO T
SOMETHING.
CYBER NINJAS GAV A
WOE EXPLANATION E STILXA
LOOKINGON, AND, YOUNOW,XP LEGAL
AY BY DAY.>> KYU L
>>> I'M JOINED NOW WCI
REFUSING TO TUIDEDY R
THERE.
ABT  WAIPLEASURE TD  ON THE
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT Y
JT CAME OTH
CRAZY TIMEH KYUNG
EDE OF THE RUBT OF ALL,  DREOING
EXTENSION OF T BIG>> REALLY TH
SAY IST
PRESIDENT ND
IME AND MONEAND NOT ON A RECOUN
VOTERS TT DO THAT TION ITSELF W
CORREC TO
I THINITOULD BE REFOR OUY ANR
PARTY.AND THAT'S T TS  JOHN McCC
WITH>> WHEYO
WHAT - DIDTH -T THROUG
MIND?L, MY ANED
TOO SO IT'E FIRST SB EENSURED IA
>> THEN IT'S A OF HONOR.
TF IT.LIEVE ME, I THK
HAS IT EVER BEEN CLE FO PRESID
REALLY DON'T KNOW ANY OYOMYS M
S AT DIFFICULT.MO IMPORTANTLY, W
WE ARE WORKING OD WHAT W
ANR IS WHAT'GOOD ABOUTERICA.
AND ITO MOVEN AND IT
ISF OUR PARTIES,
ARLYPARTY, TO TAKE AK AT ITSELH
THE PARTSION.
WE USED TO BTH
ABRAM LINCOL
THAT WE GATHER O
O WHERWEWHICH WAS A PARTY THAT .
, BUA DEMOCRAC ZED T
WORK, D MULTIPLE PARTIES.WEAT T
PARTIES WHD
ONSIBLD WH IDED THAT'S
THE  SOLUTIONSFR THE RCAY
GEBA
OUT THE ACT OF AS  I
CIVILITY, THE AC T OF A
TOGETHER BOT P TOL HILLUTARND CE
FOREVER.
S WHI TALK GREAT
IN HIS AS OF CIVITOR
COUNTRY.ACSSS FOR THE GOOD OF T
HE DIDN'T ALWAYSWAYS AGREE WITHE
EITHER.
BUT YOU RIGH
COUNTRY ANT
IABOUT. >> IT'S SUCH A CI P
NGH SI
TWEETERS AND THERE'SS TO BE --E
SOME OF THCOREG LL  MONEY AND R
THEIR PRONA.
IT DOESN'T SEE ABONG THINGS DON
VOTERS ARE OBVIOUSLY THE
KEY TO ALL OF THIS.VOTERS PEOPL
EV THESE
PEOPEIEL NOT
A GOODANTHE OTERCAMAIRCTIR STA